velasquez 10 starts this year got to be
better than his last outing when he
threw 24 pitches in the first sitting in
san francisco but then followed it up
with 36 in the second inning
swing gonna miss well that is a good
start one out here in the first
here's juan soto a 279 hitter
out to center field audubo varera
started back comes sprinting in he makes
the catch
diving forward
and the inning is over it is a much
better first inning for velasquez today
and his outfielders are showing their
speed eric fetty nine games eight starts
career against the fills with a two and
five record five two eight era four
pitch guy two-seam fastball cutter which
we will talk about at length this
afternoon curveball and change-up
curveball has been dominant to righties
the change-up has been lights out to
lefties
jammed him with the fastball
drifting for it
trey was alone on the left side one out
and this one a little tweener
but turner with his momentum toward the
back made it look a lot easier than it
was
so a two out base runner and now fetty
will face
the phillies catcher jt ramonto
in the air right
[Applause]
but
he didn't come close to getting it eric
fetty walks harper that's fine scoreless
early the end of the inning eric fetty
walked over alfonzo marquez tim timmons
they took a look at the glove tim
timmons looking at it harper
harper and listening to ryan zimmerman
and max scherzer about getting his hair
checked he does have a lot of product i
think going on in that hair well it's
pretty hair i you know i can see why
you'd want to take care of it
and now travis jankowski is coming up
appeared in 15 games prior to today all
as either a pitch hitter or defensive
replacement or pinch runner his first
start of the year
that one's hit well out to right field
soto is going back it is
gone
just under the base of the auxiliary
scoreboard a three-run home run
and the phillies take the early lead
you did smell runs
travis jankowski
the lancaster products got the hat
though the homer hat
and
into center victor robles
oh dubo herrera is now over his last 12.
but an unlikely source of power travis
jankowski puts the fills on top
so there's one away
bring up bryce harper two balls two
strikes
that one is out toward left center field
out toward the wall it is into the
flower bed just over the small fence
on opposite field home run for bryce
harper
back to back days he's homered
yeah they still are ball solos but the
phillies add to their lead it's four to
nothing over hot busy today four nothing
philly's leading kyle schwarber leads
off
swing and a miss he threw another change
up to pick up his fourth strikeout he's
got a strikeout in each inning so far
trey turner is next
turner rips one and that's beyond the
reach of alec bone it'll kick out
into the short corner area
and trey turner with his 88th hit of the
year
finally gets the nats and entry in the
book one-two pitch
over to the second base side again brad
miller waits for it
nice job by velasquez to work around the
one out double by trade turner that's
the first hit of the day
for the nets travis jankowski the
battery and the line drive base sent it
to right field
jankowski can run and he's on his way to
second
and he's there with a stand-up double
he's got a home run and now a double
tires moves the runner along
there's a line drive into left field a
base hit for velasquez
jankowski scores and the phillies add
out another it's five nothing the
nationals have runners on first and
second with nobody out starlin castro
the batter
what a pitch up castro left field line
harrison will score
avila rounding and heading for third
base starlin castro got a pitch up and
the nats are in business here in the
fifth inning nationals have robles at
the plate
in the air
but not deep at all
and the ball's on the ground
[Applause]
everybody moves up and it's a five to
two game
miller and herrera and the nets get a
huge break well that'll bring up para
the pitch
swing and miss he got 94 and that's a
huge strikeout it's the fifth here comes
joe girardi that's gonna be it for
velasquez
phillies will make a pitching change
with one out here in the top of the
fifth fitting archie bradley on for the
phillies here comes into a situation
runners first and third one out and
facing kyle schwarber
what a breaking ball let's hit well to
left
c
u
later new pitcher new ball game
schwarber number 19 in the nats of titan
bang
zoom go schwarber again
six home runs in the last four games
it fills with the chance to break this
tie
that'll bring up thereas
and that's ball four that'll load the
bases up mccutcheon is gonna be
announced as a pinch hitters one pitch
coming and that one's out toward left
field schwarber's going back toward the
wall it is gone
grand slam andrew mccutchen
off the bench
this is going to be one of the greatest
rock paper scissors of all time
and the phillies take a 9-5 lead the
walk loads the basis for trey turner he
already he kicks and throws swinging a
line drive right side base it right
field headed home castro robles will
score as well holding its second is
schwarber and trey turner brings the
nationals within a pair it's now 9-7 the
nationals who've had so many struggles
with the bases loaded had turner's hit a
moment ago and now bell gets a chance
bell
big fly
left center
c
u
later
unreal
these nationals
11 runs on the board over the last two
innings
and the nationals are in front for the
first time
amazingly
hear them